FEMA administrator Brock Long joins us
now he's in FEMA headquarters in
Washington DC good morning to you Brock
the the picture certainly look
treacherous what's your biggest concern
right now and what's your best advice
well you guys have been showing it the
inland coastal towns like New Bern are
experiencing basically the ocean rising
well we've been well we've been saying
what forecasters have been predicting 9
feet of storm surge and I'm concerned
that it's only gonna get worse at this
point because when a system like this
stalls out regardless of whether it's a
cat 1 or a cat 4 it continues to just
pump water into those back bay and Inlet
areas and that coupled with a high tide
that's going to be coming later today
it's just not it's not setting up to be
a good event for anybody yeah and your
best advice if we keep saying to people
stay we can't we told people to evacuate
as you see many of them did not your
best advice now look I mean they're you
know I can't speak for the individual
situations we wish people would heed the
warnings and and and what you just
showed on your newscast is great this is
the system at work the way we support
the search and rescue is is that we try
to pre deploy thousands of people down
search and rescue teams swift water
rescue teams to help the heroes at the
local level they're in New Bern and in
the committee the communities that are
going through this to backfill their
capability what's unfortunate is is that
these guys have to risk their lives to
go in and save people that did not heed
the warnings for whatever reason we got
a long way to go in that culture
preparedness I keep talking about and
helping people understand what their
risk are how to mitigate their situation
and just really trying to communicate
this is why we asked you to leave that
is exactly the reason we asked people to
evacuate is the ocean rising
administrator long have you spoken to
the president this morning I am
scheduled to speak with him later today
you talked about the storm stalling and
that being a big concern for you right
now it's a similar phenomenon that we
saw with Harvey obviously we know the
consequences Houston faced from Harvey
is FEMA prepared to deal with similar
effects if this storm does last not for
hours but for days over these areas
right so this is going to be a
frustrating event you're gonna see the
infrastructure knocked out this is not
something you can go in and fix while
the
storm is occurring and unfortunately
you're exactly right it's going to move
in it's less than six miles an hour
forward speed it may slow down even more
before it hooks back to the Northeast
you're gonna see rainfall measured in
feet not inches and we have
pre-positioned a lot of stuff so when it
comes to for example power we help the
private power companies to help them you
know put their mutual aid agreements
together pre-staged pre-staged their
equipment to be able to move in as
quickly as they can you know we're we're
there to support emergency
communications from the private sector
Communications acute capabilities but
this is going to be a frustrating event
and I think it's you might see similar
inland flooding damage that Floyd
presented that Joaquin presented to
South Carolina or Floyd presented to
North Carolina you're going to see a
devastating impact to the agriculture
industry in Eastern North Carolina most
likely and so we work with our partners
at Agri what we call emergency support
function 11 agriculture and industries
and then we also work with the EPA to be
ready to go for any hazardous materials
event so we're as pre position as we can
be we just have to wait and see what
Mother Nature throws at us and how long
we're what's the next stage for FEMA so
you've pre-positioned now you're
watching the first responders react when
is the next big action by FEMA in these
kinds of situations right now our
priority is taking care of people and
saving lives search and rescue is our
priority I cannot replace a life I can
read I can I can help governors and
local communities we fund a great amount
of money in the recovery to rebuild the
infrastructure and that's our focus as
the system pushes through what we'll
start to do as soon as we can get crews
in is stabilize what we call critical
lifelines the the power and fuel
infrastructure the communications
infrastructure is what we'll be focused
on we have to be able to communicate we
have to be able to get the lights back
on as soon as we get the lights back on
you solve 95% of the infrastructure
problem how long does that last that
duty I mean the storm will be gone and
FEMA will be responsible for what
happens or attending to what happens for
what period of time so so local
governments this is a partnership you
know emergency management is locally
executed state managed federally
supported but we will be with the
state of North Carolina South Carolina
Virginia through the duration of
recovery and a lot of people don't
realize that FEMA right now has over 700
open disasters that we are working
across this country half the globe from
Guam all the way to Puerto Rico and the
Virgin Islands and so we are with
communities we are a huge grant funding
grant funding agency so what we do is we
typically pay bring in technical
assistance resources to help fix
infrastructure not only months after the
disaster but years after the disaster
all right long we're gonna have to leave
it there we thank you you've got a busy
day ahead we'll be watching